JT subscribes to a cell phone texting
plan with three other members of his
family within any given month they
cannot send more than 500 text messages
total so they cannot send more than 500
text messages total at the end of this
month JT had sent 25 more text than his
older sisters let me highlight let me do
this in different colors so at the end
of the month JT had sent 25 more text
than his older sister 50 fewer texts and
his younger sister 50 fewer texts than
his younger sister and and a hundred
twenty-five more text than his mother
how many texts could JT have sent if
they did not go over how many texts
could JT have sent if they did not go
over the 500 text limit so let's just
define some variables over here let's
define well let's say OS o dot s is well
let's just say o o is for older sister
so this is number of texts text by older
sister by older sister let's say that y
is equal to number of texts by his
younger sister by his younger sister and
then we'll use M M is equal to the
number of texts by his mother by his
mother and we'll use J for a number of
texts by JT so J is equal to number by
JT so the total number of texts that
everyone sent cannot be more than 500 so
if we stake the some of JT's texts plus
his older sisters texts plus his younger
sisters text plus his mother's texts
plus his mother's text they all have to
be less than or equal to 500
total texts right it can't be more than
500 so the the sum has to be less than
or equal to 500 now how can we express
each of these in terms of the number of
texts JT sent well they give us some
information here this first statement JT
had sent 24 more text than his older
sister so J is equal to 25 plus the
number of texts of his older sister
which we say is oh it's not a 0 that's
an O for older sister and they also tell
us that JT sent 50 fewer texts and his
younger sister so J J is also equal to
the younger sister minus 50 right 50
fewer texts and his younger sister and
then finally they say 125 more texts and
his mother so J is equal to mother plus
125 now I want this equation all in
terms of J's because we want to say how
many texts could JT have sent so I want
all of these expressed in J so let's
just solve each of these for 400 in
terms of J solve for y in terms of J
solve for M in terms of J and then we
can substitute back over here so if if J
is equal to 25 plus oh if we subtract 25
from both sides of this equation we get
J minus 25 is equal to oh these are the
same thing if you just take this and
subtract 25 from both sides
you get that right there now here if you
add 50 to both sides of this equation if
you add 50 to both sides of this
equation J plus 50 is equal to the
number of texts that his younger sister
sent just added 50 to both sides and
then over here if you subtract 125 from
both sides of this equation let me
scroll over a little bit if you subtract
125 from both sides you get J minus 125
is equal to the number of texts sent by
his mother and we could have gone
straight here this first statement JT
had sent 25 more texts and his older
sister so if you take the number of
texts JT sent subtracted 25 you'd get
the number of texts by his older sister
that is an oh it is not a zero oh for
older
likewise he sent 50 fewer texts and his
younger sister so if you take the number
of text he sent add 50 to it you're
gonna get how many his younger sister
had sent and then finally he sent 125
more than his mother so if you took JT's
texts you take out 125 then that's how
many his mother sent so now that we have
this we can substitute for each of these
variables into the original equation so
you have JT's texts plus his older
sisters texts but we know that o is the
same thing as JT's texts minus 25 so we
write JT's texts minus 25 and then you
have plus his younger sisters text but
we know that's JT's texts plus 50 so
plus JT's texts plus 50 and then you
have his mother's texts but his mother's
texts are just JT's texts - 125
so flus J minus 125 and all of that has
to be less than or equal to 500 so let's
add the J's we have 1 2 3 4 J's so you
have 4 J's and let's add the constants
you have a negative 25 plus a 50 which
is 25 and then you have 25 minus 125 so
the 25 minus 1 25 is negative 100 so for
J minus 100 or just add all the constant
terms has to be less than or equal to
less than or equal to 500 and now this
is a pretty straightforward inequality
add 100 to both sides add a hundred to
both sides and we get 4 J these cancel
out and we get 4 J is less than or equal
to 600 divide both sides by 4 don't have
to worry about the inequality since 4 is
a positive number and we get J is less
than or equal to 150 so JT had to send
less than or less than or equal he he
had to send 150 or fewer texts in that
month in order for all the constraints
to match up and for the family as a as a
combined unit to send less than 500